President Eisgruber I have the honor to
present to you for the degree of Doctor
of Humane Letters honoris causa Carla
Hayden amid the unrest following the
death of Freddie gray in 2015
Carla Diane Hayden kept the doors open
at Baltimore's Enoch Pratt free library
providing a safe haven for a community
in distress during her more than two
decades at Pratt
Hayden modernized and revived the 22
Branch Library System making it a home
for people from all walks of life in
2006 re in 2016 Hayden became the first
person of color and the first woman to
serve as the librarian of Congress as
as a descendent of people once denied
the right to read and punished for
trying Hayden now leads the country's
national symbol of knowledge heralded as
a librarian freedom freedom fighter
Hayden champions open access to
information and dedication for all
akhtar Tata mejia Korra Tori Vasily
recited a spring code Orientis camisa de
ad gradum doctorís in the terrace money
or Eva's honora's causa admitto